post Johannesburg bureau chief she
chronicles her experiences in the new
memoir Mandela Mobutu and me this talk
from the politics and prose book store
in Washington DC last about an hour
my name is Cleve corner I'm the events
coordinator at politics and prose I'd
like to welcome you all here to the
store Lynn Duke was the Washington Post
Johannesburg bureau chief from 1995 to
1999 during which time she covered not
only the larger stories the devastating
Congolese war post apartheid South
Africa and the continuing AIDS epidemic
but also the impact of these events on a
village in Township level she's captured
these stories her most recent work
mandela Mobutu and me which depicts the
often Nord a much maligned continent of
Africa through stories of peacemakers
and dictators refugees and rebels
labourers and activists it is my
pleasure to introduce Lynn thank you all
for coming I really appreciate the
turnout it's my first book so I'm
becoming a pro at this I wanted to start
off by saying that the title of my book
mandela Mobutu and me is intended to
portray the two bookends of my time in
africa nelson mandela the new president
of south africa country full of hope and
i'm a boudreaux stacy seco of the
former's i year now known as the
Democratic Republic of Congo who on my
watch so to speak was in his final days
as the dictator of Zaire and also his
final days on with us on this earth so
the title of the book which was
criticized a bit in a recent review it
signifies those two bookends and the
book really is about several different
kinds of journeys it's the journey of
Nations some of the countries that I
covered South Africa journeying out of
apartheid out of the years of white
minority rule
to democracy for the majority of the
people who are black and its efforts to
attempt to reconcile the past with the
present and the future that so many
people in South Africa hope for if the
journey of South Africa also was about
ending the inequalities or at least
attempting to put policies and laws in
place to end the Equality inequalities
that were the fiber of apartheid and to
take off the books all of the the whole
sort of legal apparatus that kept
apartheid going the rewriting of a
constitution literally the the rewriting
of the almost the entire legal Canon the
changing of policies from education to
the economy to health that was the South
African journey that I covered there
were other journeys as well one of them
that was most difficult was a journey of
Rwanda after its genocide of 1994 I
didn't cover that genocide because I
wasn't in that part of Africa at the
time I was actually in South Africa
covering the elections in 1994 when the
killing occurred in Rwanda that we all
now know as a genocide but I traveled to
Rwanda quite a bit in the later years 96
97 98 and was able to chronicle a bit
and witness some of that country
attempting to put itself back together
after having lost up to 800,000 people
in the genocide and that was a
particular kind of journey that was that
is still ongoing and for Rwanda will
probably go on for decades to come
because the genocide was such a
cataclysm the journeys in the book also
include Angola I was just talking to a
young man about Angola downstairs a
country in South West Africa that like a
few others on the continent was one of
the places that was heavily affected by
the cold war by the rivalry between the
US and the former Soviet Union and where
a war tore that country from even before
its independence from Portugal in 1975
and when I arrived a that war had been
continuing almost continuously through
all those years
with a bit of a break for an attempt at
elections in 92 but when I arrived and
first went to Angola in 1995 another
peace accord had been put in place and
the country was attempting to sort of
move forward from conflict it didn't
work and the war did go on and on and so
that journey of Angola was about a
country literally falling apart under
the weight of conflict and then it also
became the story of the country
journeying into sort of being a Bigfoot
in the region getting itself involved in
wars in the Khong in both congos the
Democratic Republic of Congo the
former's a year and the Congo Republic
which is also known as Congo Brazzaville
and so during my watch angola became
sort of a regional strategic kind of
power its military could be found in a
few places around the continent
the book is also about journeys in
places like Zimbabwe Zambia in Zimbabwe
as we know from the headlines the
government of Robert Mugabe was once
considered to be a beacon of stability
and an attempt at democracy but the the
attempt has sort of fallen apart in in
in no small measure because of Mugabe
his involvement in the war in Congo but
also just because the center of power in
that country is so deeply concentrated
in Mugabe himself and in his ruling
party that repression I think in that
kind of circumstance became inevitable
and so what we're seeing today on top of
that is looming famine in Zimbabwe and
other countries of the southern African
region in in part fuelled by the
policies of the government the journeys
were about countries as I've said but
the journeys as I described them were
also about my own journey as a
journalist I first went to South Africa
in 1990 after Nelson Mandela's release
from prison he had been in political
imprisonment for 28 years most of that
time spent on Robben Island and I went
back to South Africa in 1994 as part of
a team from our newspaper to cover the
elections when apartheid officially
ended
and when I returned in 1995 to take up
the posting as the bureau chief
I was completely infected with a certain
amount of optimism this momentum that
was South Africa the ending of apartheid
the rise of Mandela and his movement the
sense almost that anything was possible
so I had this very optimistic and in
some ways it retrospectively I will say
naive view because the optimism that I
felt in South Africa I in some ways
carried over to my view of other
countries that I was yet to visit when I
first started my posting over time the
journey that I took included coming to
grips with some of the realities of
Africa but it also included coming to
grips with how to cover Africa and I did
things to get the stories that I never
thought I would have to do I mean I I
once actually sat down and counted the
number of hotels or a number of hotel
stays or stays in someone's home or in a
tent and you know it was like I cocked
them at 59 and I was like on the road
all the time there were times when I had
to climb onto the roof of a small hotel
to reposition my satellite phone antenna
to get the proper signal there were all
kinds of logistical obstacles carrying
huge amounts of cash and stashing it in
various parts of your persons to keep it
safe in case you were robbed learning
how to read a situation and know when a
bribe was appropriate when you could
resist weather resisting was dangerous
so there was a whole sense about
mastering the road that was part of my
journey as a journalist but the more
difficult one was the journey to come to
grips with that naive notion that I
began with and I went through a phase I
would sort of place it in 1996-97 during
the first war up in what was then called
as a year when I became very cynical and
despondent because it just seemed that
there were so many problems in that
region and that the international
community was willing to sit by and as
it had done during the genocide allow a
lot of F
can blood to spill without much fuss and
and I became a little bit jaded at the
fact that the dispatches that so many of
us journalists were writing didn't seem
to be having an impact the impact that I
had hoped our dispatches would have
would be to move government's to
actually intervene and create some sort
of a peacekeeping force that would save
some lives and that didn't happen and
that was sort of disillusioning and you
know I I had to grapple and sort of work
my way through that but I also found in
my journey that over time the thing that
kept me going and the thing that kept my
spirits from you know completely falling
down to ground level was the people that
I met and the extraordinary fortitude
and humanity and graciousness that I met
in so many ordinary people I was always
bowled over when I would go to interview
someone in a hut or in a tin shack and
they would have fixed tea and put out a
plate of biscuits or cookies or even
offered me a full meal there was one
episode when a I visited a family
homestead in the kwazulu-natal region of
South Africa and the matron of the
homestead while I was inside the house
which was a two room house I believe
maybe three while I was inside the house
interviewing her husband she came in
carrying a bundle I've told this story
before so forgive me if you've heard it
but it's it's just one that touched me
so she came in carrying a bundle of
newspapers and I out of the corner of my
eye wondered whom what's that and then
it became kind of moving and fluttering
as she approached me and it was a
chicken and she was offering me a
chicken as a sort of a traditional way
of greeting me into her home and they I
saw their chickens outside they had a
few chickens and they weren't well fed I
mean they needed that chicken and you
know it was one of those moments where
you have this sort of massive cultural
confusion what do I do I'm travelling in
a rental car can't put a chicken in the
rental car you know but if I don't take
the chicken will her feelings be hurt
and I
get up not taking the chicken much to my
chagrin and I always regret regret that
but it was just one of the many gestures
that that I witnessed from people who
really had very little in their lives
materially speaking but spiritually were
incredibly rich and deep people and so
part of my journey was understanding
that the grounding for me in Africa were
the people and what that meant in terms
of how I viewed governments and how I
viewed policies from the outside world
was the sense that there needed to be
more programs and more aid and more
attention paid to improving the lives of
ordinary people and that's another
reason that is a reason why in the book
in my authors note which is at the very
beginning of the book I describe myself
as not an afro pessimist which is a
brand of person who just thinks you know
Africa is going or has gone to the dogs
and there's no reason to be concerned or
nor an afro optimists which is someone
who believes that everything is going to
turn out alright and and is very
defensive about the negatives in Africa
I called myself an afro realist and the
reason I did that is that I was up close
and right in the throes of some of the
chronic problems in Africa in some
African countries the problems of
governmental corruption of chaotic
bureaucracies of violence some of it
ethnic violence and you know so I can
not in good conscience claim that
everything is going to be alright
because I have seen how it is not and I
have seen reason to believe that there
will continue to be problems but as I
said before to me the the spirit of
Africa lies in the people who are legion
I mean ordinary people who continue to
live lives that are dignified to make
the best of their situations and many of
them put themselves at risk to try to
help their communities to be human
rights monitors etc and to me that's
that's the hope and the heart of Africa
and so I call myself a realist to
combine those two elements yes there are
problems but you know you can't turn
your back on this huge body of people
that are real people who are worthy
our attention and and respect I think so
the book has these different journeys
that I weave together in a way that I
found to be of course I would say this
engaging but I also hope that you will
as well I wanted to read a few
selections and and talk about them
before opening it up to questions in
case any of you have them I start the
book in Congo Zaire because it was a
time when the going was perhaps toughest
it was it was September it was August of
1998 it was the start of the war that is
continuing in that country and I've
found myself there with a host of other
correspondents who were on hand to cover
this war because it was turning into a
real siege of the city of Kinshasa which
is the capital of of Congo Zaire five
million population and so this would
have been if it happened a significant
battle as a significant Cataclysm I
think so
this is an experience this sort of
captures some of the experience that I
had as a journalist grappling with a lot
of different issues and problems to do
my job I hated it when the lights went
out I still had a dispatch to write for
Washington was awaiting my daily file
but there i sat oiled again fumbling for
my flashlights and candles as the whole
of Kinshasa capital of the Democratic
Republic of Congo was reduced to the
darkness of a village it was August 1998
in the midst of yet another Congo war
and those damned rebels had done it
again
they'd seized the country's main
hydroelectric plant and taught sit
taunted Kinshasa and me with another
nightly blackout I fumed to myself as I
lit a candle and welcomes the eerie glow
it cast over my room I lodged up on the
14th floor of the Hotel Intercontinental
and down below as far as the eye could
see across the sprawling metropolis
cooking fires and candlelight speckled
the darkness like stars fallen to the
ground
my people African people were suffering
again and my people African people were
the cause this was getting pathetic I
pored through my notepads
jam-packed with days of scribbled
shorthand and raced against time as I
wrote I could only hope my laptop
battery would outlast the night's power
outage only hope I'd make it through
another Washington deadline night after
night my dispatches grew more ominous
the rebel juggernaut pressed clover
closer to the capital food shortages
deepened ethnic cleansing swept the
streets massacres unfolded all around
the country President Laurent Kabila is
regime girded for a fight that his
splintered army could not win the United
States France Belgium and Britain
evacuated their Nationals but had no
intention of rescuing Kinshasa itself so
African leaders stepped into the void
assembling a response of their own to
the bloodbath that many feared would
consume the city's 5 million people that
was my fear too the days ahead would be
dangerous I didn't know how I'd make it
through I had a fever and needed sleep I
needed a hot bath and clean water that
wouldn't plant strange bacteria on my
skin sick with the bends from the
hotel's lovely display of a faintly
rancid buffet I craved fresh food and
what I wouldn't give for a doctor to do
something about the infected boil on my
face it bulged from my cheek like a
third eye it assaulted my vanity each
time I looked in the mirror and
disgusted my colleagues as they watched
the boil grow strangely it reminded me
of my mother back in Los Angeles if she
could see me now
I laughed to myself mom thought mine
such a glamorous profession and regaled
friends and relatives with tales of my
travels but I am certain she never
imagined that a foreign correspondent
for the famed Washington Post could look
as worn and diseased as I'd become on
the road in Africa at war and so I start
the book with that because I wanted to
you get the jist when you read it but I
wanted to sort of set up one of the more
difficult passages or journeys that I
had to make
and it does have a pretty strong impact
on things that happen later in the book
and you know dealing with things like
illness when you're reporting overseas
and dealing with all the logistical
nightmares truly takes up a lot of your
time I mean there was an episode when I
finally got a doctor to write me a
prescription to get healed and I had to
go through six roadblocks with child
soldiers with their aks to get to the
one pharmacy and kinshasa that was open
so desperate was I to get something to
take this thing off of my face was
really painful it was horrible I didn't
even look at the medicine I knew that
the name of it but I didn't sort of look
at the dates and you know you can
imagine the rest I got even sicker
because it was expired it was bad it was
kinshasa what should I have expected
right so anyway that was just a glimpse
of what it was like to be on the road I
also wanted to read a bit of a sense of
the if I can get to it here a sense of
how I perceived my identity as an
african-american while I was in Africa I
basically wrote this chapter which is
called an african-american woman
specifically to look at the various
pieces of my identity and what it meant
when I was on the road and this is what
this particular section is about I claim
Africa as a political act as an afront
as an act of affirmation it is my
private way of staying true to the
legacy of the struggles that link black
people on both sides of the Atlantic in
our blackness the Africans and the
Americans are bound by a common
experience the construct of racism
became for both peoples the pretext that
Europeans used to justify their
domination in Africa and in America the
struggle against such racism defined
both peoples for generations and
continues to define us still that is why
I call myself an African American in
honor of our common struggle but there's
some tension on both sides of my
compound identity after all Africans
sold my people into slavery that is an
original sin
and I do not overlook it nor do I
overlook the fact that it was Americans
who bought those slaves and held him in
bondage for generations more some black
Americans trip Oh with a very phrasing
of the term African American it's bulky
as it rolls off the tongue and it's the
latest in a long string string of group
label labels either forced on us or
embraced by us over the generations but
it's a it's the African part of the
phrase that gives some people pause
Africa even for many of its black
descendants in America conjures images
of foreboding and menace even
backwardness ignorance about Africa runs
rampant among us I have heard one too
many a black person referred to Africans
as people who wear grass skirts others
who perhaps know more of Africa have
been so repulsed by Africa starving
children its murderous mobs and its
thieving dictators that they have
decided they simply cannot claim the
African part of their identity whole
books have been written on the subject
mostly built on the false notion that
American this and African asar somehow
mutually exclusive as if we are to make
a choice for me it is not that
complicated my people became American
because of what was done to Africa the
histories of both lands inhabit my
consciousness and course through my
veins
it is a visceral bond that for many
people is automatic
even an old Zulu man who knew little of
the outside world knew kinship when he
confronted when it confronted him
his name was Johanna sandblow vu and I
met him in 1994 during South Africa's
historic election he lived deep in the
valley of a Thousand Hills a rural area
of the kwazulu-natal region where he'd
walked for hours in his rakish straw hat
and dusty blazer to get to the voting
booth to exercise his brand-new
democratic right I was traveling that
day with Frank James of the Chicago
Tribune and seat bocas while our guide
and translator when we introduced
ourselves mr. Enlow who became so
fascinated with our blackness that he
conducted an interview of his own after
hours was through we were the first
foreign black folk he'd ever met it was
my honor I am very happy to see black
people from America my own blood mr.
anvil Andrew
who said to us I used to hear people
saying black people overseas left Africa
a long time ago
I only know there are black people
overseas how they got there I do not
know we explained that we were
descendants of people taken from Africa
and transported on ships to America as
slaves with that we immediately struck a
familiar chord the old man has spent his
life as a sugarcane cutter on an
apartheid-era farm he knew a thing or
two about repression ah
he said when we told him of slavery we
are the same but but I go on I won't
read everything I go on to to say to
offer a whole raft of caveats to that
which sort of made the experience of
navigating my own identity and how I was
perceived by others a really sort of
rich part of vatic of the experience of
being in africa of course there were
strange adventures that broke out while
I was over and I'd like to read one more
thing to you if you don't mind because
this was one of those times when you
just never knew what was going to happen
during the Congo Zaire war as you may
recall there was a massive refugee
crisis there were more than a million
Rwandan refugees living in camps in the
former Zaire and when the war started
they were scattered they found
themselves at the frontline of a war and
actually many of the people in those
camps were actual fighters in that war
the scattering of the refugees became
something of a crisis and it was one of
the few times that the international
community actually rose up and decided
that they would do something which they
ultimately didn't do but at least for a
minute it looked like they were there
was going to be some intervention so a
group of us hatched this idea I'll read
it to you from Kinshasa the five of us
journalists had hatched a harebrained
idea that we'd fly to Kisangani
and transfer to a smaller plane that
would buzz the jungle so we could spot
the missing refugees despite their huge
number the terrain was so rough so
inaccessible and so overrun with hostile
forces that the UN and international
relief groups had been unable to figure
out
where the refugees were in our misguided
valiance we were determined to find them
the plan had its risks even more risks
than we knew but frankly at the time I
was so pumped up at the prospect of
getting closer to the action that the
dangers did not sink in other
journalists had gone to Kisangani
recently without serious in his hat so I
figured we could pull it off too but one
of my friends I'm a Logan wife of daily
ole ojd and also a journalist in
Johannesburg thought we were nuts she
phoned from South Africa and tried to
talk daily out of going then she phoned
me and warned that we were just being
careless and trying to win Pulitzer
Prizes I told her not to worry that
everything would be fine
and it was at first we each secured
government passes to travel and finally
aborted our Chartered 727 and the pilot
captain Pasquale maimie
Wei Maha who'd studied in Texas and in
Belgium was quite amused to be ferrying
a group of foreign correspondents and we
were quite amused to be flying in an
otherwise empty 98 seat jet the flight
attendant served us meals complete with
wine and we settled in two hours of
silly chitchat and roaring laughter
about everything and nothing but Amma
was right of course
we were flying right into a maelstrom as
we finally landed in Kisangani I had a
sinking feeling that this was indeed a
very bad idea
I could see soldiers running toward our
taxiing plane in fact soldiers were
everywhere in no particular order on the
tarmac some troops wore uniforms others
were clad in little more than rags some
were even barefoot and all of them were
angry and wired an ugly crowd gathered
down below as the rolling stairway was
pushed into position against our planes
door I dread at the moment that door
would open for I had no clue what form
of chaos would roar into the plane but
when the soldiers finally piled into the
cabin with their awesome equatorial funk
and file soldiers breaths they really
weren't all that interest in us what
they really wanted was to get as far
away as possible from the war
Marcus talked us off the airplane and
onto the tarmac where our contact the
small plane operator found us herded us
into a vehicle and told us to forget
about doing anything at all in Kisangani
except staying alive until we could get
out
he had already been beaten that day at
the airport and
driver waiting for someone on the tarmac
had been shot we headed to the Palm
Beach hotel a small 1970s hotel on the
rivers north bank the day of our arrival
the tripod mounted machine guns awaiting
action at strategic positions in and
around the grounds were the hotel's most
remarkable feature we ran into a trio of
British journalists at the palm beach
who'd arrived a few days prior with the
same bright idea to search for the
refugees but they'd been taken hostage
and hostage in Kisangani by soldiers who
beat them pointed guns at their heads
stole their money and released them with
a warning to leave the city and now at
the palm beach our traumatized
colleagues warned us to get out - so
yeah it was what they call a laugh riot
you never knew what was gonna happen
a final brief selection that I would
like to read which is right now very
much in the news after hearing President
Bush's State of the Union last night
when he made what to many was a surprise
announcement that the US was going to
dramatically increase its funding on the
International hiv/aids crisis in South
Africa HIV was a problem that was
escalating with such speed during the
time that I was there that I don't think
the government was even aware of how
devastating it was going to be and those
who were aware found themselves really
unable to to sort of cope with looking
at ways to treat it it was so soon after
the transition from apartheid it was
almost like a blow to be hit with this
virus that was set to wipe out a segment
of the population and I covered some of
it and I want to read you just a little
bit of the chapter entitled coffins and
whispers busi seaway Chia moved like a
ghost as if she'd already departed this
world a lacy yellow nightgown draped her
body and fluttered lightly with each
small step she had been sick for several
months but when she awoke that February
morning in 1999 she felt stronger than
the day before
a day of convulsing pain she'd wanted to
be outdoors to get a breath of
err fresher than the stuffiness of her
gingy room at replay Hospital a place
overrun with AIDS I walked a bit with
her just outside the entrance to her
ward best not to venture too far I
thought she really ought to have stayed
in bed she may have felt stronger but
she didn't look at her sunken eyes
seemed unfocused her voice sounded raspy
a mere whisper her arms quavered
quivered at her side suddenly her knees
buckled she tottered sideways and
collapsed against me in a swoon I caught
her beneath the arms before she hit the
ground and steadied her steadied her
while a nursing aide rushed over to help
walk her back to her room I hadn't
noticed until I touched her that busi
Seaway was wet all over I could feel the
moisture on my hands a mixture of her
perspiration and perhaps a bit of ooze
from her rashes and lesions as we
settled her back into bed I reminded
myself not to touch my eyes or mouth
until I could wash up i sat with her for
a while until I was until I realised she
was too weak to talk anymore she
clenched her trembling fists to her
chest as she dozed off to sleep blessed
is the English translation of her Zulu
name but in South Africa at that time
Boosie Seaway was among the stricken so
I will take questions thank you
are you gonna oh yes sir that was very
good very interesting thank you
three series of treatments of antibiotic
finally got rid of it you know it was
pretty persistence wanting to learn
about their answers that's very good
but hyphenated Americans seems to me a
cell bank you don't hear any more about
Irish Americans italian-american you
don't see these times family water and
with the time when it was when there was
great integration that was a very common
expression it's really not used
we're all Americans I understand your
sentiment I don't think that using the
term African before the word American
detracts from American this because
Africans as we were brought over were
very much part of the fabric of the
creation of and the founding of America
and all groups don't have to have the
same kinds of names so I think that's my
feeling on it I mean we don't all have
to have - some of us do and some of us
want to other questions yes shed some
light prior to the genocide on the role
of the Canadian general roméo Dallaire
who consistently warned the UN who paid
no attention and to ambassador Kruger
who was so upset not getting any
response from the State Department that
he filed his messages with the press
roméo Dallaire just to let you all know
who we're talking about roméo Dallaire
was the general who was heading the
United Nations peace force that was in
Rwanda at the time in the months
preceding the genocide and in the very
during the genocide actually and mr.
delare was a figure who was aware of
intelligence intelligence data that was
from an informant who said that there
was that a planned slaughter was
underway that a that plans for a
slaughter were underway and that weapons
were being distributed and that lists
were being compiled and this information
was transmitted to you in headquarters
and it did not spur a larger peace force
indeed the UN Security Council decided
that the best action would be to
withdraw most of the peace force that's
who mr. delare is and you I'm not
familiar with ambassador Kruger I must
say so I don't think I can really speak
to that part of your question yes
I don't have any pictures of it I'm
sorry it's only one small part of the
book like there's a 294 page book and
that's like one paragraph
I know it seems to be catching on you
know I don't know what to say well thank
you for putting together you know the
work which to me it shows what Africa
means to Africans everywhere well
whether they're with different citizenry
or their student Africa we have these
different points of views of Africa but
what I find out what I find consistent
with what I have read about the 40 pages
which I have read so far you seem to
confront a situation where Africans are
like irresponsible very corrupt in that
they fight against each other causing
all this destruction and also negligence
on the part of what's going on poverty
and everything that's going on but as a
journalist you have come from here in
America do you do any somehow see the
responsibility of foreign policies
impacting these situations in Africa yes
to an extent certainly I mean and I and
just to clarify he's asking to what
extent foreign policy can impact the
situation in Africa mm-hmm
there is no one single factory of guns
in the air the guns are made in America
in Angola we have estimated 20 million
landmines they are made here in
Minnesota so what kind of what do you
what relationship do you see that you
can put responsibility towards what
foreign countries are doing to Africa
and what Africans parties
what do you see as well I think that I
think that you have multiple layers of
responsibility I mean look the arms that
Africa is awash with yes in the main
they are produced off the continent with
the exception of South Africa which has
a significant arms manufacturing
industry so the arms trade is a is a
huge problem for a continent where there
are conflicts and where there are
vulnerable populations who can easily be
harmed in those conflicts I think that
efforts to stem the arms trade it's one
thing efforts to deal with the conflicts
there's a different thing one side is an
African responsibility one side is an
international responsibility I mean I
think that in a broad sense what I would
I would say is that cold war policies of
the West so-called West as it pertains
to Africa had a lot to do with what was
going on in Angola had a lot to do
certainly with the zyre situation
because the Cold War had the u.s. in a
position of wanting to try to trump the
Soviet Union and to do that it needed
its favored leaders in Africa Mobutu
Sese Seko was one of them Jonas Savimbi
and Angola was another so I think the
overall cold war policy created a
dynamic and sort of a paradigm in Africa
that was not to the benefit at all of
Africans as I think history has told so
I think in the main the responsibilities
are are there multiple on the part of
Africans themselves but also the
international community does have some
responsibilities yes straight ahead
to that you made reference to Robert
Mugabe of Zimbabwe right now and
President Lee
libecki in South Africa has made
reference to wanting to achieve an
Africa the trivalent amongst African
nations - what they've achieved in
Europe with the EU and I think there's a
lot of question I have friends in South
Africa that are questioning why someone
like President rebecky
is not more vocal in taking on President
Mugabe and Zimbabwe a man who has very
cavalier he said if six million
Zimbabweans die of starvation they could
do with six million less in Zimbabwe and
and people are wondering why there isn't
a stronger African voice taking beyond I
think part of the the question in just
basically was why aren't leaders such as
president Thabo Mbeki in South Africa
being more vocal in criticizing or
taking on Robert Mugabe and the
situation in Zimbabwe I would think I
would say that part of the answer to
that question goes to the heart of
liberation politics in Africa I mean
these are countries who all became free
from either colonial or minority
domination over the past three decades
South Africa being the most recent among
between those two and I think that the
notion that there's still a great
defensive nough stored the Europeans and
Americans when it comes to telling
Africans what to do and I think that's
one of the reasons you don't find in
Becky or other African leaders strongly
denouncing what's going on in Zimbabwe
there's also I think a fear that to
exacerbate the political situation in
Zimbabwe is to court huge waves of
refugees flowing into South Africa
across that border that they share I
think a combination of those two things
helps to explain some of it yes
yes first I'm like oh I'm sorry first I
want to say that the book is excellent
just really so well written and
combining the history and information
with just a very engaging
you know prose but I wanted to know
since you were in southern Africa at
such an incredible time so exciting but
also you know sometimes dodging bullets
doing your cousin and now what are you
doing now and how do you deal with them
here you don't have to worry about the
electricity all the time and you know
it's just a very different life and so
how you know well I've gotten over the
Vertigo I would say in my first year
back it was this constant sense of okay
I was there and I was racing here and
there and I'd see a story in the paper
and I would say that's my story in my
territory I should be doing it you know
and then there was I did have sort of a
bit of vertigo when I returned about
sort of where I had expended so much
emotional capital and where I kind of
still was stuck in a way I mean what I
can out what I can do is write the book
which helped me to relive a lot of those
times and I follow the news pretty
astutely or aren't pretty frequently I
should say you know I enjoy what I do
now but in the first year it was really
hard because I just had this feeling
that there was there was sort of a
mission to the journalism that I did in
Africa because Africa has been so
maligned in some quarters of the media
and I thought that there were there was
such an opportunity to illuminate things
in Africa that had sort of been left in
the dark and that's kind of what I felt
I was doing or at least trying to do and
you know journalism here in the States
as equally is exciting etc but it
doesn't have that momentum where events
are so crucial that people's lives hang
in the balance and there was that sort
of sense in Africa so you know I've sort
of gotten over it but it was a little
bit of a rough transition I must say yes
in the back
thank you good journalists writing them
and they're not as good as they used to
be I don't think Nelson Mandela and his
role in foreign affairs I'm interested
in your thoughts about that and what you
think he thinks about his role in
foreign affairs I know already spoken
out recently against the potential war
against Iraq for example and I wonder if
Nelson Mandela would ever think of you
know before the war happens or after it
happens really doing a major campaign
with the media as I think one of the
most probably the most respected person
on the earth if he would take a major
stand on that maybe some people would
listen what do you what do you think the
psychology is there of him and thinking
about Foreign Affairs I really don't
know to be honest but I think I think
it's safe to say that statements urging
statements speaking against war and
urging peace are pretty much I would
suspect the extent to which she's going
to go because Mandela right now is very
very very immersed in southern Africa in
the fight against hiv/aids and that's
like a whole separate war in a way and I
would tend to doubt that he would go
much further than he's already gone but
but I really don't know that's we're in
such a different territory now with
terrorism and the threat of war with
Iran it's just sort of hard to say how
that is impacted on the political
equation from where South Africa sits
looking at the outside world okay
tomorrow yes
we were in South Africa back in the 50
to the 70s
I'm not never going to go back there
again under apartheid we were back there
last September and had several days in
Cape Town with some black African
friends who took us around I had gone
with somewhat naive hope that Nelson
Mandela the great change would have
taken place some things would have been
infinitely better and of course they are
better in some to some degree but the
impression that I got from our friends
was that the police are as bad now in
South Africa as they were under
apartheid in terms of the way they treat
ordinary people and they were rather
discouraged because Becky is not Mandela
and it seems to me that all over Africa
the problem has been leadership you can
find great people who come come to power
of Jomo Kenyatta Kenneth Kaunda and even
Mugabe when he began but as time goes on
it sort of deteriorates what hope do you
see for the future of the African
countries in terms of finding leadership
that's going to try to really stick in
there and do the right thing well I
think it's a country-by-country question
I think in South Africa that there was
no way that Thabo Mbeki was going to be
able to be a Nelson Mandela no one could
do that
he has to be frank disappointed on on a
few fronts based on what I'm hearing
from people in South African based on
some very obvious issues such as his
positions on the hiv/aids crisis in
Botswana there's a very I think a very
remarkable leader festival hi who has
taken a very strong lead on dealing with
the AIDS crisis I think that's an
example in Senegal one day is also a
believed to be a very strong leader I
think that
leadership rises out of political
systems and the problem in Africa is
that political systems still have a
combination of the old paradigm from the
colonial days even at this late date
with a new kind of elitist corrupt kind
of government style of government having
taken hold
I can only be hopeful that in time
that's going to change
I think the prospects are very mixed
there are many countries where there has
been conflict for so long that it's hard
to tell what will come out of out of
their systems of leadership I think I
would just say that for me that the
prospects are mixed well yes the state
of race relations are yeah yes the
question was could I talk about my own
interactions was socially with white and
black South Africans and could I broadly
summarize the state of race relations in
South Africa it was it was very
interesting um
I lived in a community that had been
under law all-white under apartheid
that's where our Bureau was based and
that's where I moved when I moved to
South Africa wherever whenever I was in
my community people who didn't know that
the Washington Post lived in that
community assumed that I must be
someone's maid because the only black
faces in that community and in many such
communities were black maids and black
gardeners and so I'd go to the front
gate to accept a package and they'd ask
you as your madam home and I'd be like
there's no madam here you know and try
to be polite but it was pretty
infuriating and that speaks to the fact
that even you know even several years
after the transition from apartheid
there was a very calcified notion of the
sort of configuration of race of the
races in term
of economics and social position I
interacted with black South Africans
quite easily I had friends and sources
in the townships in government whatever
whatever and when I say black South
Africans I mean I'm a non-white really
I'm talking about the old spectrum I
interacted socially also with some white
South Africans because you know when
you're a foreign correspondent in a
country you cross all of the lines
that's your role and we had ferocious
debates on all kinds of issues and
sometimes they were raucous and ugly and
sometimes they were you know we were all
on the same page it was a very kind of
fluid and dynamic interaction for me
because there I always encountered sort
of a an unexpected perception both of me
and perhaps of African American in
general I encountered that both from
Africans as well as from whites white
Africans I might say and so navigating
that percept that the terrain of
people's perceptions was was always kind
of interesting you never quite knew what
you were going to come up with the state
of race relations I mean South Africa is
12% white and the rest people of color
the majority are black colored is the
apartheid-era designation said an Indian
and the locations in which people live
are so so much defined today by
apartheid that I can't see that changing
anytime soon
the the new black elite of people in
government people in managerial and and
executive levels and business etc are
moving into the areas like the one where
I live that is definitely happening but
I think there is still from what I'm
hearing I went back to visit in October
2001 and it seemed very clear that
there's still a sense of your places
there we're expecting that blacks are
going to be there and whites are there
and there's not a whole lot of
intermingling socially most black South
Africans live in townships or villages
that's just a fact there are no unless
it's really changed dramatically white
people living in townships maybe a
smattering
here or there I don't know if you guys
ran into any when you were there but
it's it's highly doubtful the townships
are the third world by and large and the
cities are the first one I'm like those
terms a whole lot but they help to sort
of show the huge gap and I think that
the attitudes of apartheid haven't gone
away and in fact have in a way been
compounded by the demons that people had
to confront through the process of truth
and reconciliation which I think was a
much needed and and laudable process I
think that not all South Africans were
ready for it we're ready to be called to
account we're ready to have to confront
what apartheid was about and by that I
mean white South Africans throughout the
process of the Truth and Reconciliation
Commission in hearings all over the
country I went to many of those hearings
and by and large the audiences were 90
percent black very few whites attended
these hearings and they were open to the
public and they were each cathartic
events and I I spoke to Archbishop
Desmond Tutu about it and he said that
you know it turned into a fact of the
truth Commission's existence that whites
were not connecting in a visible way and
maybe in the privacy of their own homes
they were going through was some sort of
a catharsis and coming to grips with the
new social equation of South Africa but
it was not visible and indeed there was
sort of a backlash mostly among whites
but to an extent even among some blacks
against the truth and reconciliation
process because many whites who did not
accept the idea that they benefited from
apartheid and therefore you know perhaps
should have some contrition they
rejected that notion the attitude you
often heard from some South Africans was
there was an election they took power
what more am I supposed to do but on the
on and these are all generalizations by
the way for black South Africans there
also was a sense that apartheid era
killers and torturers and bad people who
had maimed people and ruined people's
lives and
like hell were allowed to walk away and
not pay a price and the people who
suffered also walked away without
anything being done to repair them and
that engine has engendered some
bitterness among like South Africa as
well Lin do currently writes for The
Washington Post New York Bureau Mandela
Mobutu and me a news woman's African
journey is published by doubleday visit
Random House dot-com / Doubleday for